[Music]
had i made a video like this say
five or six years ago i'm fairly certain
that a large majority of fans of the
zelda series
including me would have answered with a
resounding no
no no but as of late i've seen more and
more people being open to the idea or
even flat out calling for nintendo to
break the tradition of link's silent
demeanor and give him a proper voice
i myself started to think about this
more when gerard khalil aka the
completionist addressed this in his
review for breath the wild back in 2017.
i will say and maybe a ton of people
will really disagree with me on this but
i think it's time to give link a voice
as well as angry joe's take on the
matter
and i get that he's supposed to be you
and you're supposed to project yourself
onto him but in my opinion it's 2017
and those are born from older game
limitations
and since then i too have slowly become
more open to the idea of nintendo giving
it a shot in future installments
now i'm not here to tell you whether or
not link should have a voice or not
i'm just here to give my two cents on it
and no matter which direction nintendo
decides to take it i will always remain
a loyal fan of the series either way
so if you disagree that is totally fine
and i actually encourage a discussion on
the matter because
at the end of the day we all want what's
best for the series right
so what is it about a voiced link that
has people on the fence
and why is nintendo been reluctant to
give it a try even to this day
obviously in the early days it was
mostly due to technical limitations
primitive sound chips and limited
storage capacity gave devs a hard time
incorporating good quality sound and
music into their games god knows they
tried though but it wasn't exactly the
most pleasant thing to listen to
but as technology advanced this became
less and less of a problem
still even to this day audio is one of
the biggest culprits when it comes to
the enormous file sizes of modern games
alongside high quality textures while
nintendo is known for its innovation
when it comes to gameplay experiences
both in terms of software and hardware
they have also lagged behind on the
competition on multiple occasions
and nowhere is this more clear than in
the mid to late 90s
the n64 cartridges could only hold up to
64 megabytes of data
which is less than your average music
album meanwhile sony fully embraced
cd-rom technology which could store
up to 660 megabytes more than 10 times
that of the n64 cartridges it is no
surprise then that the majority of games
featuring a fully voiced cast
pre-rendered cutscenes and non-midi
soundtracks are found here when it comes
to this generation of consoles
the pc obviously being in a league of
its own still even on the n64
some games manage to incorporate plenty
of voiced sections
games like perfect dark and conker's bad
fur day which also happened to be among
the biggest games on the system in terms
of size for obvious reasons
however ocarina of time only utilized
half of the storage capacity of its
cartridge so it's not like you could
make the argument that they weren't able
to at least have some spoken word in its
cut scenes
it's clearly something they either felt
was unnecessary or didn't fit the game
and
honestly i don't blame them the audio
quality for voices
wasn't exactly the greatest back then
due to the heavy compression needed to
make it fit on the cartridge
plus there wasn't really a high standard
for voice acting in video games yet like
there is now
if anything voice acting in ocarina of
time would have probably dated the game
a lot more
but gaming has come a long way since
then nowadays you could fit every n64
game ever made onto one single switch
cartridge which is kinda crazy to think
about but even when technology had
already caught up
nintendo was still hesitant to take it
to the next level even as late as 2006
nintendo was still resorting to mostly
midi tracks for the music in the legend
of zelda
twilight princess the same year that
oblivion made its debut which not only
featured a fully voiced cast
even for the most obscure npcs but also
a fully orchestrated soundtrack to go
with it but one thing that oblivion and
later skyrim and zelda have in common is
that the games feature a silent
protagonist
apart from the occasional grunts they
don't audibly speak neither during
gameplay or in cutscenes
silent protagonists have been around for
a long time and will likely always stick
around
and in oblivion the silent protagonist
approach made sense since you create
your own custom avatar to your own
liking
you can be a human an orc a furry mark
zuckerberg whatever floats your boat
a big part of role playing games like
these is making a lot of choices
you can be a lying stealing murdering
son of a bee or a goody two-shoes who
does
everything by the book or somewhere in
between this makes it very difficult to
present a cohesive cut-scene heavy
narrative
i mean it's kind of hard to be heralded
as a big hero the pinnacle of morality
and bravery when you just got done
murdering the local blacksmith because
he looked at you funny
but these issues don't matter for the
zelda series because the games have
never been
heavy on choices you play as a
pre-established hero set on a
predetermined path and with a specific
physique and skill
set and unlike games like fallout and
skyrim you don't get to choose whether
or not link is good at bartering or how
much charisma or intelligence he has
you don't get to murder innocent
civilians or step out of character all
of a sudden
no matter what kind of person you are
link will do what is required of him to
complete his adventure
sure you can waltz into a stranger's
house and smash up their pottery but
aside from that and a few small choices
here and there it has little to no
impact on the actual outcome every
cutscene will always play out the same
way
and the end goal 2 remains the same and
that is how zelda is meant to be in my
opinion
i don't want zelda to become like
oblivion where i can make link do the
most horrible things and yet still
somehow be heralded as a hero but that
doesn't mean that giving him a voice
ruins or changes that experience
in fact as early as zelda 2 it's already
been made clear that link does speak
and across the whole series this is
confirmed time and time again
characters who ask him his name and then
reiterate it based on his answer
every dialogue choice you make is him
saying that sentence causing the other
character to react accordingly heck we
even hear him speak in the wind waker
only two words but hey it's a start no
matter how shallow
some of his incarnations are every link
does in fact have a distinct personality
of their own
i mean can you honestly put wind waker
link skyward sword link and breath of
the wild link next to each other and
make the argument that they are all the
exact same person but with different
looks
heck no that is why when it comes to the
argument that link
needs to stay silent because he's the
vessel through which we experience the
adventure i have to say
sorry but i don't buy it i don't buy
this argument anymore
there are tons of examples of games
featuring a voice protagonist which
still
allow players to step into their shoes i
don't know about you but when i play
uncharted or horizon zero dawn
i find no issues projecting myself onto
nathan drake or alloy
i mean eloy i can still be that
character despite them having a
completely different
personality than that of my own after
all narrative driven video games are
often about stepping into someone else's
shoes and experiencing their journey
regardless of personality physique or
gender
in the last of us i am joel in tomb
raider i
am lara croft in tetris i am the tetris
block
needless to say not every game needs a
voiced protagonist when i play luigi's
mansion 3 or animal crossing i never
think to myself
man why can't these characters just have
normal conversations instead of this
weird semi-gibberish
i mean the games aren't exactly plot
heavy they're meant to be simple fun
adventures centered around gameplay and
while gameplay is equally important in
the zelda series
it is also one of nintendo's more
cinematic and story-driven ips and it's
clear that nintendo thinks the same way
given the fact that they recently
introduced voice acting it's clearly a
step that they felt was necessary to
take the series to the next level
and here's the thing breath of the wild
still kinda managed to get away with
having a silent link because it kept its
story to an absolute minimum
all the voiced sections are saved for
cut scenes only which are few and far
between
the rest of its story is told through
its environment and during gameplay it
still falls back to text-based
conversations
and you know what i'm totally fine with
that in fact i think there's a charm to
reading the dialogue and imagining the
conversation in your head
i've never been the biggest fan of the
modern day approach where you and the
npcs stare awkwardly at each other while
they exchange words
something always seemed a bit off about
having your character just stand there
dead-eyed while you choose your dialogue
option but that's just me
another problem with this approach is
that you're never going to be able to
have hundreds of voice actors for
every npc in the game which often
results in a lot of reused voices and
not every voice actor
is gonna be as good as the others it
doesn't ruin my experience of a game by
any means
but i just can't imagine something like
this in a zelda game i am more than
happy if they just stick the text based
conversations for the majority of the
gameplay
cutscenes is a different story however
as of right now we don't know what
breath of the wild sequel will do when
it comes to its narrative so it's hard
to say if a voiced link will even be
necessary in that game but if it's going
to take even the slightest bit of
inspiration from age of calamity then i
feel like nintendo might need to
consider giving it a try
because age of calamity is where the
first cracks in this silent approach
really started to rear its head this
game has a lot of cutscenes like
three hours worth of cutscenes and
here's my main point
the more people around link start
talking the more awkward it's going to
become to have him stay totally silent
in previous games everything was based
on dialog boxes in ad-libs which was
fine for the time and
it was consistent but now that close to
every character has started speaking
link stands out more and more as this
weird anomaly
okay i just realized how inconsiderate
and insulting this can sound to someone
who's
actually mute in real life so i want to
make it clear that i am by no means
saying that you are weird in fact you
are awesome
i'm just talking about video games here
like i said before link isn't really
mute
people ask him questions he answers the
only reason we don't hear him speak is
because nintendo simply refuses to do it
just wanted to make that clear anyway
breath of the wild broke a lot of
conventions and in some aspects it seems
like nintendo still had one foot in the
past
and didn't dare to go all the way with
it if nintendo plans to continue this
trend of having a fully voiced cast
i think it would be wise if they choose
a more consistent format
generally games have three different
approaches when it comes to dialogue
either everyone speaks everyone but the
protagonist speaks or nobody speaks and
it's all done through text
body language or gibberish and ad-libs
there are examples of games which do the
same thing as breath of the wild
they don't feature a wide array of
narrative choices and have a
pre-established main character yet still
choose to have a silent protagonist
while everyone else is voiced
half-life being a good example of this
now don't get me wrong the half-life
series is absolutely amazing
it is to this day in my top 10 favorite
franchises of all time
but even here the silent approach to the
main character gordon freeman is
starting to show its age if you ask me
especially since there isn't really a
point to him being silent anymore in
half-life 1 most npcs didn't contribute
much to the story other than to help set
the mood for the chaos and devastation
inside the laboratory besides this game
came out in like
1998 but in half-life 2 and even more so
half-life 2 chapter 1 large portions of
the game sees alex vance accompanying
you on your journey through city 17
and she talks quite a lot in fact she
has a very strong personality and is
actually one of my favorite companion
characters in any game to this day
at the time it didn't really bother me
that much but looking back at it now i
can
kinda see the awkwardness of having one
character talking your ears off
and the other well not talking at all
and similar to link it's not like gordon
is incapable of speech either
he is but for some reason we don't hear
it we're supposed to imagine it i guess
this creates this weird dynamic where
alex basically has to reiterate to the
player what it is that gordon might be
saying to her
and who knows it might even be the
reason why their latest game half-life
alex has you play as her
instead of gordon if what is being
speculated is true and we see link and
zelda work together a lot more in breath
of the wild too
it's unavoidable that we get the same
dynamic scene in half-life 2
where zelda has to act like link is
speaking or ignore the fact that he
isn't
and act as link's voice and has to
reiterate his imaginary dialogue to us
this would be fine of course but if the
goal is to see these two form a closer
connection
having links stay silent might get in
the way of that there would always be
this brick wall where link isn't able to
express his feelings and emotions
properly
now suppose nintendo indeed decides to
give link a voice
this of course doesn't mean he has to
all of a sudden be an open book and
rattle off dialogue after dialogue in
fact it was one of my gripes when i
recently played horizon zero dawn for
the first time
i love eloy as a character but this
chick talks to herself
way too much for my taste i know she's
supposed to be an outcast who's used to
being on her own and stuff but
i think they took it a step too far red
light
yes that means no power a holographic
interface
must be some kind of code resources
that makes one that's two okay i did it
sounds like that didn't if i find more i
should be able to get to that ancient
armor i found
it doesn't even really feel like she's
talking to herself because she's just
weird that way but rather because she's
trying to give constant exposition to
the player
i hate this in movies and i hate it in
video games too
i know this is personal but when i'm
exploring a dark and spoopy hallway i
don't need to constantly hear the
character's thoughts on the situation
it works when you have two characters
who are sharing their thoughts and
observations with each other but on a
solo mission it just comes off as if the
devs are directly trying to tell you
what's going on in case you missed it
so when it comes to link i'm all for not
having him talk during gameplay and as
for cutscenes you can still have a
protagonist who doesn't speak much
but once in a blue moon having them say
at least something would already go a
long way
i mean even silent bob at least says
something once in a while when it's
necessary
just [ __ ] say it already
the sign on the back of the car said
critters
of hollywood you got
again i want to reiterate that this
argument is based on the assumption that
breath of wild sequel will focus more on
the bond between link and zelda if this
is not the case and the story is equally
as minimalistic as breath of wild
a voiced link may not be necessary and
they might want to save it for a future
title one that's more story driven like
skyward sword
so with all this in mind i get the
reasons why people might still be on the
fence about the idea of link speaking
the first one being bad examples set by
past
experiences we all know what i'm talking
about
i can't wait to bomb some dadongos yes
the cheesiness of the 90s sure did put a
dent in people's confidence when it
comes to link being voiced but we have
to keep in mind that none of these
cringe fests were made by nintendo
themselves
and i don't think this should dictate
whether or not nintendo gives it a shot
in their own creations
i think with the release of breath the
wild and even more so age of calamity
nintendo has shown that they are more
than capable of presenting believable
characters with the right voice actor
not always of course which leads into
the next point the fear of choosing the
wrong voice
and yeah this is a fear i can totally
get behind
choosing the right voice actor can make
or break a character we've already seen
a bit of a divide when it comes to
zelda's voice
some think she's fine while others are
less enthusiastic about it let's just
put it that way
if the voice of the main character is
off it could hamper the enjoyment of the
game which also ties into the next
aspect
a general fear of change change can be
difficult and scary
especially with a series that's so
dearly beloved by its fans
we already caught a glimpse of this
during the announcement of the wind
waker back in 2002
safe to say a lot of people were not
happy with the sudden change in art
style
of course this sentiment was quickly
brushed away by most once we saw how
amazing and charming the game actually
was
and i think if there's one fan base that
should be open to change is the zelda
community
we are used to change this is a
franchise that has altered its art
styles gameplay and so many other
aspects so many times since its
inception
the series is one of the most
experimental ones out there and
one of the reasons why it's still going
strong after so many installments
some might argue that it would be weird
if link all of a sudden starts talking
especially if it's the same link from
breath the wild and age of calamity
well i mean dead space did the same
thing and nobody complained about that
in the first game isaac was silent which
was fine because he was alone and
isolated for the majority of his journey
but as the games became more story
driven and more voiced characters got
involved in death space two and three
the devs made the decision to give him a
voice
i think it would be a shame if the idea
of a voiced link is scrapped altogether
just to play it safe how will we know if
it's an improvement or not if they never
try
even if it fails i doubt it would
completely ruin a zelda game altogether
the gameplay will undoubtedly still be
amazing
now you might say zelda doesn't need
voice acting to be good and
i agree the series has been more
incompetent in portraying its story
without the use of spoken word but just
because something is already good
is that really a valid argument not to
try something new or would you miss out
on the opportunity to make it even
better personally i think the latter is
the case here what if it ends up working
extremely well
maybe five years from now we wouldn't
have it any other way breath of the wild
broke so many conventions for the series
some for the worst and some for the
better but the good changes have been so
monumental i honestly can't imagine a 3d
zelda game releasing after this that
doesn't have climbing that doesn't
feature something akin to the paraglider
or the physics and chemistry engine what
if a voice acted link ends up being
another one of these improvements
is it worth playing it safe for the rest
of the series lifespan
just because of the fear that it might
not be an improvement
i will leave that up to you to decide me
i am more open to the idea than ever
before
thank you all for watching a shout out
goes to my amazing patreon supporters
and channel members who make these
videos possible
some of which have recently joined the
cause so give a warm welcome to
johnny peacock glenn clecker zedon
dragmiyer
yoshi 6500 and dare del avid you guys
are the best
thanks a lot for your support that is
all for now this is don
signing off and have a good one
[Music]
you